I am sitting here with my father and we
would like to understand why the
commitment made has not been fulfilled
tell the director that I would like to
resolve this now before it gets out of
hand and now means tonight and Z if I
get a call or text from anyone involved
in this other than you Zhang or the
chairman I will make certain that
between the man sitting next to me and
every person he knows and my ability to
forever hold a grudge that you will
regret not following my direction I am
sitting here waiting for the call with
my father
that is a text message from Hunter Biden
to Henry Zhao an influential member of
the Chinese Communist Party whom the
first son was shaken down for money on
July 30th 2017.
it's about as smoking a Smoking Gun on
corruption as there is and maybe Hunter
was bluffing
maybe I want to be as Fair as I can be
maybe Joe Biden wasn't really sitting
next to his son when his son sent that
text we know that Joe has gotten
involved in Hunter's crooked Affairs in
the past we know that Joe Biden
threatened to withhold a billion dollars
in American Aid to Ukraine unless
Ukraine fired a prosecutor that was
investigating a shady Ukrainian company
that paid boatloads of cash to the Biden
family we know all of this we've got
texts and photos and videos
unfortunately we know
that no Biden or Clinton or any Elite
Democrat is going to be prosecuted for
it Hunter Biden might get probation on a
tax misdemeanor or two
as the GOP Presidential primary heats up
the main debate right now between all
the candidates is over electability
is Trump too obnoxious to win moderates
is DeSantis two straight lace to fire up
the base fair questions
but those are secondary questions in
2020 liberal Elites were so hell-bent on
stopping a second Trump term that they
shut down the country and changed all
the voting rules to benefit them
our current president and his family can
commit egregious corruption and crimes
documented by gigabytes worth of texts
photos videos
they all get off scot-free
the leader of the opposition Donald
Trump kept some presidential documents
like all of his predecessors have
mishandled classified information maybe
like the big prominent Democrats have
and they're trying to lock that guy up
for Life the chief question of
electability is not whether a candidate
can appeal to Suburban moms the chief
question of electability is whether the
system will still allow a Republican
presidential candidate to get elected at
all I'm Michael Knowles is the Michael
Noel show
[Music]
welcome back to the show really
important news breaking which is that a
Bud Light is digging the hole even
deeper for themselves just digging and
digging and digging they've got a new
commercial out can't wait to get to it
first though on electability
that's what this campaign's about Trump
is running on the Trump campaign
DeSantis is also running in the Trump
Lane
you've got a bunch more moderate
candidates or candidates running a
campaign like it's 2008 and it's not
they're not going anywhere there are
still some candidates coming out of left
field but if you look at the poll
numbers it's Trump versus DeSantis they
both have the same campaign platform so
the campaign is about electability who
can win and then wield power and there's
a new poll that just came out from
Emerson College which
I think shakes up some of the
conventional wisdom on this
conventional wisdom right now is
DeSantis has a much better shot at being
elected than Donald Trump maybe that's
true maybe with polls you know a polls
and a buck 50 we'll get you a cup of
coffee but according to this poll
both DeSantis and Trump lose to Joe
Biden
and according to this poll actually
according to this poll Trump does better
than DeSantis against Biden according to
Emerson 44 would vote for Biden 43 would
vote for Trump
and 43 would vote for Biden versus
DeSantis and only 37 percent would vote
for DeSantis
but here's where it gets kind of weird
if Cornell West the leftist populist
candidate is in the race on Election Day
then
only in that circumstance does the
Republican win
Trump 41 Biden 40 Cornell West 6 percent
you know me I am the most skeptical of
polls and statistics broadly as anybody
gets but especially this far out
especially National polls but this is
really interesting not because what it
says about Trump and DeSantis not even
really what it says about those guys
versus Joe Biden
it's the Cornell West thing Cornell West
pulls votes not from Trump but from
Biden
Cornell West has something in common
with both Trump and Biden which is that
he's a leftist so he has something in
common with Biden but he's a populist so
he has something in common with Trump
and what we see here is that when a
leftist populist gets in the race he
pulls from the leftist candidate
which would help the right-wing populist
candidate
and which tells you that there is lots
of room for a populist movement to grow
in 2016 there were a lot of Voters who
came out and said I've never voted
before or I've always been you know
maybe a Democrat but now I'm voting for
Trump
the phenomenon of the Trump Democrats
just like you said the Reagan democrats
back in 1980.
some people think well there's just a
ceiling on the support that Trump can
get there's a ceiling on the support
that a populist candidate can get
this poll suggests that's not true I
think there's a lot of room for a
populist candidate to grow now maybe
Trump's got his supporters and there's
not a ton of room for for that to grow
unless Joe Biden completely creators
which is a totally plausible scenario
but
in terms of populism generally cracking
up the sort of uniparty Monopoly and the
the stale old talking points and the
stale of priorities of both parties
there's a ton of room it would seem to
grow you'd grab five percent from the
libs immediately and if you had a
candidate who was better than Cornell
West you could probably grab a lot more
than that if you think that populism is
over or on the decline as I think a lot
of establishment Republicans are hoping
is the case I think a lot of
establishment Republicans frankly are
hoping that if Jerome gets a nomination
in in 2024 that he loses and then the
GOP can finally reset to the good old
Happy Days of Mitt Romney and I don't
know ASA Hutchinson and all these
squishes and they can become Democrat
light again
I don't think that's going to happen I
don't think that's what the numbers show
and people are going to be talking about
that a lot over the next 18 months when
you want to talk to your friends you got
to check out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles a company I'm proud
to stand behind and that is proud to
stand behind us and our country is pure
talk veteran owned with a 100 American
Workforce they share our beliefs that is
why Pure Talk is the official cell phone
wireless partner of the daily wire but
that's not the only reason Pure Talk
also happens to be the most Dependable
5G Network in the U.S they're a top tier
provider at a fraction of the cost of
other woke companies you know which ones
I'm talking about ATT Verizon T-Mobile
companies that don't care about you or
your beliefs mix and match your plans to
fit every person in your family
choose from talk text and 5G data for
just 20 a month all the way up to
unlimited data with the mobile hotspot
for 55 dollars a month you vote with how
you spend your money so stop supporting
woke wireless companies that do not
support you go to puretalk.com Knowles
you'll get great coverage and save while
you're doing it go to puretalk.com
Knowles you will save an additional
fifty five zero percent off your first
month because they value EU go to
puretalk.com
wireless for Americans by Americans I
want to get back to Hunter Biden because
Hunter Biden who I have not hammered on
this show I know some right wing hosts
they talk about Hunter Biden all the
time most of his Shenanigans I think are
not all that interesting they're just
sort of depraved and gross and sad but
these really are interesting the man is
the poster child for the corrupt Elite
and he's committed all sorts of crimes
in virtually every genre I think and he
gets off without so much as really even
a slap on the wrist he'll get maybe some
probation for the tax misdemeanors and
then he goes into a diversion program
for his gun charge but I think Jenna
Ellis found this still on the doj
website
it would appear that Hunter Biden is not
even eligible for this diversion program
which is a way to avoid jail time and
eventually have the gun charge expunged
from his record because the doj says
absent approval by the office of the
Deputy attorney general any pre-trial
diversion program created by a U.S
attorney's Office shall exclude any
individual who is
accused of an offense related to child
pornography accused of an offense
related to Serious bodily injury or
death and then here's number three
accused of an offense involving
brandishing or use of a firearm or other
deadly weapon
we can see we have photographs of Hunter
Biden brandishing his weapon
so
they're probably at the doj they're
going to try to to be really really uh
specific about the definition of
brandishing to exclude whatever Hunter
did
or they're just going to ignore it like
like our prosecutors do so often now
when it involves politically favored
people and groups are going to say okay
never mind now one of the criticisms of
this corrupt Elite ruling class and the
way that Hunter Biden is just getting
off with a ton of crimes no big deal is
it going to say well you know the lower
class never gets off with these kinds of
crimes oh it's those rich
politically connected people they get
away with murder but the the poor people
on the street they never get away with
anything and that's not exactly true
these diversion programs are largely for
lower class people on the street with
all sorts of records and all sorts of
bad neighborhoods plenty of Street
criminals and gangsters get these exact
deals
I mean this is the whole point of the
Soros prosecutors
the the leftist installed prosecutors
who get into their jobs and they stop
Prosecuting Street crime because they'll
say well if we prosecute certain crimes
it's more likely to
involve black people and that would be
racist and for racial Equity we're going
to let gangsters back onto the street
we're going to pre-trial diversion
programs and we're going to give them
you know Bond and we're going to let
them off on probation and all the rest
of them they go commit more crimes the
distinction here with the corruption of
the doj and the prosecutors more
generally is not that it's the rich get
one set of rules and the poor get
another set of rules Donald Trump's
pretty rich and they're going to try to
throw them in prison for the rest of his
life because he kept his own
presidential documents for a little bit
because he committed crimes that all of
us spread crimes and all of his
predecessors committed and that
Democrats who never even were president
have committed
no it's not a it's not a rich versus
poor thing it's just a politically
favored versus politically disfavored
thing if you are
a black street criminal in a Democrat
City
you are more likely to get off the hook
for crimes you'll be put in one of these
programs and if you are the degenerate
first son the son of the president who
commits all sorts of crimes you're more
likely to get off too and if you're a
conservative and if you threaten the
ruling class
whether you're poor whether you're in
the middle whether you're rich they're
going to throw the book at you
you could be a poor and deplorable
hillbilly irredeemable white guy from
the from the red States you could be a
Midwestern granny who was taking some
photos in the capital rotunda on January
6th the worst day in history or you
could be a billionaire president of the
United States doesn't matter if you
oppose the ruling class that's when they
go after you
last thing with Hunter there's another
story out
as I've said I don't really like to dig
in too much to all of his personal Saucy
disgusting scandals because
they're just Audrey and they don't shed
much light on things this one does
though Hunter Biden was a member of an
elite La sex club called sanctum sanctum
it's just like all businesses that were
started around 2012 and 2013 all these
Millennial businesses from you know
Consulting startups to sex dungeons
apparently they took the vowels out so
it's snctm
uh it's a private members Club
that prioritizes the safety and privacy
of their esteemed members above all and
it involves a ton of Hollywood
celebrities and big people in the news
media and
I won't I won't name the names but
they're you can read about them they're
really very prominent famous people and
apparently the club was founded
after the movie Eyes Wide Shut came out
so it's not just that eyes wide shot
parties really exist remember Madison
cauthor and the Republican Congressman
mentioned that there were Eyes Wide Shut
parties in DC and then he was
immediately just ejected from Congress
well well it turns out the eyes wide
show parties they happen in Hollywood
they're really involve very wealthy
famous people and they're consciously
eyes wide shot parties they're based on
the movie eyes wide shot so anyway the
club cost 75 grand a year to become a
member and includes actors rock stars
CEOs even City officials according to
the LA Times and Hunter Biden was a
member of this club
what's most striking about the existence
of this club is not that it involved
Hunter Biden if something is degenerate
in America over the last 15 years
there's a good bet that Hunter Biden was
involved in that
what's striking about this club is that
it's no different
from
activities that have taken place since
the dawn of human history among depraved
Elite esoteric
immoral people it's been going on
forever just after I read the piece
about the elite La eyes wide shot sex
club I read a piece about an ancient
Egyptian cult that got high on
psychedelics and drank bodily fluid
cocktails
this is just a story I think it was on
The Drudge Report 25 year old 2500 year
old ancient Egyptian cult used to get
high on psychedelics drink fluid from
places that they shouldn't drink it from
and also also had all sorts of alcoholic
drinks and drugs and archaic Vaz from
the era resembling the deity Bez who is
some Demon that the ancient Egyptians
worshiped of fertility and War showed
traces of psychoactive substances the
cult members who took the drug would
experience delirium hallucinations and
heightened libido they would use this to
trip during their religious ceremonies
and the religious ceremonies would
involve orgies would involve all sorts
of orgies and
weird gross activities this is the same
thing as the LA Eyes Wide Shut sex club
the LA sex club is called sanctum
sanctum meaning holy coming from the
word to consecrate
the LA sex club I guarantee you involved
a lot of alcohol and drugs
so and then
it involved a lot of weird ideas about
what a human being is and how we relate
to one another and and what is sacred
it's not just that these guys were
getting their jollies by bumping uglies
in some weird dungeon in Los Angeles
they considered this to be holy the way
that our society talks about pride month
and all the weird sexual rituals
involved with pride they speak about it
as though it is Holy as though it is
virtuous as though it is a kind of
religion because it is it's it's the
same old kinds of Cults it's the same
old kinds of demon worshiping Cults that
we've had since 3000 years ago in
ancient Egypt
and people
often don't realize when they're an
occult people often don't realize when
they're engaging in religious rituals I
bet a lot of the guys at that sex club
they just think they're having a fun
time and they're cool and they're modern
they don't believe in anything man
they're doing the exact same thing
as an ancient Egyptian cult consciously
worshiping demons can't get away from it
human nature just just Remains the Same
as speaking of parties
and weird sex stuff Bud Light has a new
ad out
and I'm just going to catch you up
really quickly on the timeline Bud Light
sponsors put some on a beer can
the the
Bud Light sales tank
people revolt against it
Bud Light doesn't apologize
but like sort of doubles down then Bud
Light blames it on some VP of marketing
and puts her on leave and I think maybe
fires here I don't remember I think
she's probably gone
then Bud Light doubles down on it then
Bud Light makes a commercial about
horses then Bud Light still won't
apologize for the beer can
as the sales continue to tank then Bud
Light begs people to buy their beer
again but Bud Light still won't
apologize and now
Bud Light has this commercial
a a true work of art a truly
completely ignorant wrong-headed work of
art on why you should buy Bud Light
again
[Music]
there we go it's a older white guy
rubbing Bud Light on his face
[Music]
people fall in a Bud Light gag
what a bunch of goofy dumb stupid pick
idiot room Bud Light records I keep
stumbling and falling
[Music]
now it's kind of windy oh look at this
dummy you can't even get to a hammock
[Music]
yeah this guy came they've got to know
how to tap a keg that stupid Bud Light
drinkers
[Music]
there we go we got more
middle-aged white guys
I don't know I don't know what the
commercial is trying to tell you other
than
middle-aged white guys
and kind of fratty looking guys the two
main constituencies for Bud Light
uh they're just a bunch of stupid klutzy
idiots now buy our beard dummies
it started out with that VP of marketing
saying we hate how we've got this kind
of fratty you know Vibe of of Bud Light
we just hate we want to switch it so we
want to embrace the cultured beautiful
serious sophisticated
people and then the actual audience for
Bud Light went away they said all right
you sloppy filthy deplorables whatever
here let's here's a couple pictures of
you stumbling around because you don't
even know how to put two feet in front
of you yeah okay drink it up drink up
our slop you gonna buy it yet no that's
probably not gonna work not very
effective even if they're just trying to
return to normal and say hey Bud Light
is just what you drink at a party it's
easy to drink please buy or drink again
here's what I have to say
until Bud Light
tweets out my CPAC speech the
eradication speech in its entirety with
three thumbs up emojis the boycott
continues
I hereby decree
and I think you will see that reflected
in the market cap okay
We're Not Gonna We're not gonna look
we're not We're not gonna just stand by
and allow Bud Light to make us look that
bad and when you want to look really
good by the way you got to check out gen
you sell right now go to geniusell.com
Knowles what is the biggest summer
secret to a great looking glowing summer
complexion it's having great skin care
products from our friends at gen yusel
dehydrated skin covered in dark spots
puffier bags under the eyes that's a
problem for all of us genius sells
beautifully curated summer Essentials
package is a limited edition package
that includes their one-of-a-kind Ultra
retinol super moisturizer their Ultra
retinol is a powerful plant extract
alternative to retinol without the harsh
side effects and is perfectly safe to
use in that summer sun plus you will get
genuine cells classic skincare therapy
for under eye bags and puffiness and
concentrated vitamin C serum to nourish
your skin for a visibly clear complexion
with a glow that will get you
compliments everywhere I love genucel I
think the product works great it's
terrific and also I love the founder who
is a Coptic Christian from Egypt who
came over here for the American dream go
to geniusell.com Knowles right now get
your Genius Health summer Essentials
package just for the summer every
subscription order includes a customized
summer spa gift box totally free
geniusl.com Knowles head on over to
geniusell.com Knowles
folks I am introducing to you
the precision5 razor one handle plus one
blade cartridge kit for only 14.99
Jeremy's lowest cost for a razor and
only for a limited time it's crafted
with a luxurious tungsten handle five
welded steel blades and a flip back
trimmer for a close smooth shave around
hairlines and hard to reach places but
remember the Precision 5 is no ordinary
razor it's a sword in the battle for
beliefs a banner to wave into a new
economy a Precision instrument of force
woke companies to earn back your dollar
and stop denigrating your beliefs it's
also still a razor and will give you a
great shave the Precision five is
starting at 14.99 with a price so low it
has never been easier to stop giving
your money to woke corporations that
hate you join Over 125 000 men who have
ditched their razors and switched to
Jeremy's there's never been a better
time or Price go to jeremy'srazers.com
today
[Music]
strong
wrong
foreign right now head on over to
hillsdale.edu Knowles are you a few
years or maybe decades out of school and
wondering what the heck did I even learn
and what was the point you might think
to yourself that you don't have the time
to learn something new if that's you
know this you're not alone it's not too
late since 1844 Hillsdale College has
been providing education in faith
freedom and character they've taken some
of the core classes they teach on campus
and made them available for free online
for anyone who wants to learn that is
right for free there are 39 free courses
to choose from ranging from the U.S
Constitution the Book of Genesis the
free market and much more they are easy
to follow they're self-paced so you can
start whenever you want in fact you can
start right now it's everything you need
all in one place with no long-term
commitment let Hillsdale College be your
guide learn when and where you want to
go to hillsdale.edu Knowles to enroll no
cost it's easy to get started
hillsdale.edu Knowles Canada w-l-e-s
hillsdale.edu Knowles
finally finally
we've arrived at my favorite time of the
week when I get to hear from you in the
mailbag the mailbag is sponsored by pure
talk at puretalk.com
off your first month take it away
hey Michael this is Camille and I have a
quick question for you so I'm in the
market for a new roommate and a guy
friend of mine who is just a friend but
it can get kind of flirty sometimes ask
if he could be my roommate he says he
thinks we'd be great we get along really
well and I do love him as a friend but I
just wanted to know do you think this is
not a good idea even if we are just
friends thanks
what do you think Camille what do you
think I think about that
what do you really think about that I
think by your very question you know the
answer
that's not a good idea
look we're just friends
we're just it's totally platonic I mean
it's a little flirty sometimes but it's
not and it's fine I kind of like him but
mostly just as a friend is it a good
idea if we move in together with all of
our hormones and all of our natural
attractions is that do you think that'll
work out well
uh no maybe you should date this guy I
don't know but if you date the guy you
definitely shouldn't just like move in
together
before you start dating forget about
before you start getting married good
grief uh no could be a bad idea if you
have a roommate you should have a girl
roommate
sometimes a little flirty come on
Camille uh next question
good morning Mr Knowles this is murder
of crows I highly appreciate you taking
your community's thoughts and questions
I have a thought that I would love your
reaction to I will not be voting for
Donald Trump this election cycle
primarily as you have pointed out in the
past that Trump is only going to be able
to serve for years his continual attacks
on Ron descentes currently give me pause
specifically if Donald Trump is not
thinking forward in the future his
attacks currently on Ron DeSantis will
greatly inhibit
Trump's ability to support Ron DeSantis
in four years regardless of who wins on
the high assumption that Ron DeSantis
will run again in the next election
cycle how is Donald Trump going to then
back Ron DeSantis with all of the
predation that he's putting on Ron
DeSantis currently and then switch sides
and say no Rhonda Sanchez is a really
great guy I'm going to support him in
four years thank you for your time you
have a wonderful day
very easily Trump does that all the time
you remember when when Trump said that
lion Ted was you know the most dishonest
person he ever met he puts his hand on
the Bible and then he lies lies
l-y-i-n apostrophe lion Ted and then
what happens when Senator Cruz is
running for re-election to the Senate
Trump comes in and he says oh we got
beautiful Ted over here yeah maybe I
used to call him other stuff but now
he's beautiful Ted I love Ted he's great
he's a great Senator you should all vote
for him so Trump does this all the time
that that would not be hard for him to
support DeSantis say in in four years
but
uh beyond that
Trump is going to attack DeSantis
because DeSantis is his chief rival in
the race that's normal that's just
called running for president and
DeSantis is going to attack Trump and
then if Trump is the nominee DeSantis is
probably going to endorse him
and if DeSantis is the nominee this time
Trump I I don't know if he would endorse
him but if it were next time say if
Trump had served another term and then
DeSantis rep he'd probably endorse him
if he were the nominee maybe even
beforehand that's rough and tumble
politics but furthermore I think what
DeSantis understands very keenly is
political timing DeSantis is the man
right now he is
at I think the height of his political
Powers as governor of Florida I don't
think he's going to become more
prominent and more powerful than later
into his second term it gets because
he's going to get term limited out in
2026 so then there's going to be two
years between the time he was governor
and the time that he could run for
president
that's a that's a lifetime in politics
and some new Ron DeSantis might pop up
in the meantime so I think the governor
sees okay this is my moment I have to
run now but running against Trump is a
Surefire way for Trump not to pick you
for vice president so if Trump were able
to serve four terms he'd probably
endorse whoever he picked as his vice
president assuming that that person
didn't get on his bad side during during
his administration and so it it DeSantis
just recognizes okay we're not playing
low stakes here
I'm going to try to kind of Curry favor
with Trump we're going to run a kind of
a nice primary and then maybe he'll
endorse me next time this is all or
nothing he says this is my moment I'm
gonna run and if I don't win then maybe
I can try to run next time but this this
is my moment right now and Trump is
thinking the same thing and then who
knows in four years you could have a
totally different guy four years ago did
Rhonda Santos look like he would be one
of the leading candidates for president
no
he didn't a handful of people saw that
he had a lot of political potential but
among why voters no not really
same thing with Trump four years before
2016 did people think Trump was going to
be the nominee no politics moves very
very fast these big boys with thick skin
they know what they're getting into next
question
hello Mr Noel Slayer of neocons and
owner of Libs long time viewer here
first time messaging using a friend's
account actually and I would like to
thank her for that anyway I've got two
questions first one is how does it feel
to be the best host at the daily wire
and the second question is to what
extent do you think the second amendment
applies like starting with machine guns
going up to tanks and nuclear bombs My
Views we should basically have access to
anything the government would
realistically use against us as long as
someone's willing to sell and sellers
are not immoral this would mean nukes
are off the table because I don't think
no matter what the crap people in power
would ever have the cajones to Nuke
American soil this would mean repealing
the NFA and abolishing the ATF very
interested to see what you think because
this is looked at as a more libertarian
view and I'm a traditional Christian
conservative not a naive thumb sucking
libertarian thank you for your time and
look forward to your response
that might be the most beautifully
written question I've ever received on
this show
it's real how does it feel to be the
best tester daily wire it feels great
and you are a traditional Christian
conservative and not in your words a
naive thumb sucking libertarian so you
you are espousing a more libertarian
point of view here but
I get it I feel you the Second Amendment
is very important the right to protect
ourselves is very important my answer on
these questions and my interpretive
principle I guess for for how to make
sense of the Second Amendment is one
that takes into account history takes
into account the original public meaning
sure of the Second Amendment and also
takes into account prudence and I think
that's what you're saying as well
as you say I think the people should
have access to any weapons that the
government has well the government has
nuclear weapons which you which you
address and you say I just don't think
they'd ever actually use that on us
maybe that's true maybe that's not true
but now you're introducing an element of
prudence here to distinguish between the
weapons that the civilians can have and
the weapons that the government is
permitted to possess and so I would
apply apply that as well
and I would strongly curtail the
anti-gun anti-second Amendment
activities of you know the federal
government through the ATF or whatever
I'd be happy to do all of that but I
wouldn't give you some firm you know
this is the cutoff weapon
Tommy Gun is okay but the Bazooka is not
okay or whatever I I think
you you ought to apply this
Rule prudentially and practically by the
way one of the biggest
reasons why the libs have been unable to
curtail our Second Amendment rights is
because Americans have so many guns it
would just be if Americans had fewer
guns they would have confiscated them
already the fact that there are many
more guns than people in the United
States is one of the reasons why they
just kind of give up and so
another practical way that I would
defend the Second Amendment is I would
encourage people to just buy guns and be
responsible with them obviously store
them properly know how to use them know
how to use them especially but the the
way to defend a right is
less effective through a judicial ruling
much more effective through practice and
tradition which is what I would base my
interpreter principle on next question
hi Michael this is the shukmeister I
wanted to thank you for inspiring me to
finally read Dante I just finished The
Inferno and it was so good I couldn't
put it down I'm starting purgatorial but
I was wondering which part of the Divine
Comedy is your favorite and why love the
show thanks great uh probably Paradise
actually The Divine Comedy is three
parts most people have heard of Dantes
Inferno but you know there's the second
part which is purgatory and the third
part is heaven and
The Inferno is very sexy because it's
got all these brutal punishments and you
know which part have I read the most
probably The Inferno over the years
because it's just so Saucy and it's the
one that everyone reads but prurgatory
is really brilliant
I I
I love lots of purgatory and the images
in purgatory but then in Paradise
you'll just cry you know it's just so
beautiful especially at the end of
paradise and there's all sorts of
brilliant stuff throughout the whole
Canticle but uh in particular I
sometimes refer to when Dante meets his
ancestor his illustrious ancestor
kachiguita in heaven and cut your way to
complains about immigrants coming to
Florence and ruining the city which is
just great and gives them some other
political advice on partisanship but and
then there's
oh goodness there's so many so many
wonderful parts of the poem but then at
the end when Dante is beholding the
godhead
the last time I read it this is sort of
embarrassing I was sitting there I was
catching up I was doing and I was
reading an English translation of it
because I Was preparing to do it for the
uh the book show at prageru and I'm
sitting there reading the last three
kantos and I'm just sitting at my desk
crying
crying like a little baby because it's
so beautiful so yeah you know make it
all the way through even if you look at
Medieval manuscripts of Dante you'll see
that there are all sorts of notes you
know marginalia in in Inferno and that
kind of slows down over time so if
you've never made it to the end of the
poem you're in very good company it's
true even of medieval monks but you
should try to make it to the end because
it's very very good okay today's fake
headline Friday baby the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
oh